que le constructeur qu'en est-il de
cette bataille dite de personnes qui se
préparerait qu'en est-il de la présence
militaire russe dans la région des
rumeurs laisseraient entendre qu'il
serait en train de se replier qu'en
est-il vraiment l'univers Craig et notre
correspondant à Kiev
c'est le gouverneur de la région nommé
par les Russes le collaborons kirit le
strebou sauf qui a dit hier que
probablement les forces russes
retireraient se retireraient de la rive
droite de la région d'aersonnes donc de
la ville derrière sonne mais les
analyses les observateurs disent que
même si on voit que certains bloc poste
semblent être abandonnés à d'autres
endroits les Russes se semblent
renforcer leur position défensive alors
les Ukrainiens peines à interprété
exactement ce à quoi joue les Russes
peut-être qu'effectivement sous la
pression de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne ils vont se retirer mais il
se peut aussi que ce soit une sorte de
piège je pense que l'analyse que c'est
une pièce est plutôt celle qui est
privilégiée en ce moment par les
militaires Ukrainiens qui devons
certainement pas avancer tout de suite
vers la ville en pensant que c'est bon
que ce ne sera pas défendu par les
Russes